wenn du zum ersten mal gemüse anbauen
möchtest dann solltest du diese drei
kandidaten auf jeden fall in einen
bepflanzten weil die so unkompliziert
und quasi von selber wachsen
das so eigentlich überhaupt nichts
falsch machen kannst kandidat nummer
eins ist die zucchini die wachsen
eigentlich immer und eine einzige
pflanze reicht schon aus um genug
zucchinis wie eine kleine familie
abzuwerfen und kandidat nummer zwei sind
die radieschen die wachsen nämlich super
schnell so dass man nach drei bis vier
wochen schon die ersten ernten kann
der dritte kandidat ist der knoblauch
dafür einfach meine knolle
auseinanderbrechen und die zehen mit der
flachen seite nach unten in die erde
stecken und das beste ist nach der ernte
kannst du einfach ein paar von den
knollen aufheben die wieder in den
garten pflanzen und dann hast du bald
überall knoblauch